he is Seth worker shimma of ESPN and
ESPN dot-com thanks for calling in Seth
hey great to talk to you again you
better you robbed
I'm good you've given us a lot stew to
chew on right here how long have you
been you know digging into the Browns
organization for this piece Seth um I
don't know exactly you know what what I
think
look tension in a building that's not
exist I think they're like what matters
is when there's something real that's at
stake and when I saw a Baker Mayfield
become a force in Waiting during the
second half of the season I am not
automatically was thinking like you know
what is gonna happen here because this
could go great or it could be read right
88 the drive the fumble the shot and
Baker Mayfield and that's what I was
trying to try to understand is in you
know how decisions are made what it's
like to work for Jimmy has amande what
this means when you have a precocity on
quarterback who looks like he's gonna be
a superstar for a long time yeah and
that's it and that's why I wanted to
have you on is because much of your
piece
dives deep and very detailed into the
banner Lombardi to Shashi brown years
and then when it comes to the here and
now I'm wondering what you were able to
glean about the ultimate question which
is what you just said is why you started
deep digging in here is what do you
think is going to happen based on what
has happened before with Baker Mayfield
in John Dorsey now with Freddie kitchens
that the the troika that is now in place
of quarterback general manager and coach
Seth I have no idea and that to me is
what made it so fascinating because
you've had a consistent run under under
owner Jimmy has some of these sort of
arranged marriages and Jimmy ends up
being the arbiter or the tiebreaker and
it creates a bunch of backstabbing and
mistrust and problems and obviously
losing and that's your gonna you know
how important it is for young
quarterbacks to have continuity
I mean look at Alex Smith how many
offensive coordinators that guy had
during his first five years of his
career and so where Baker may feel to
succeed Jimmy haslums gonna have to do
two things that he has not done before
one is hire well and the other one is be
patient and stay the course and won't
just see what happens I mean I think
that like there's some reasons for hope
given that Freddie kitchens is clearly a
John Dorsey hire and that he will report
to John Dorsey and not to Jimmy Haslam
but we'll see I think that like the jury
is out so in terms of the flow chart
best you can tell they're in Cleveland
because again all these stories about
what was happening with you Jackson and
what was happening with Sachi Brown and
what happened with banner and what
happened with Lombardi and what happened
with very Farmer I mean that would just
keep me up at night I knew how bad it
might have been but this really puts
into black and white just how bad it was
do you think that Dorsey is in charge
and and haslums just gonna let him do
his thing right now do you think I think
so I think so and I mean I think that
Dorothy's got a lot of political
maneuvering and power in there because
he did draft make her Mayfield but we
will see I mean I think that like you
know I reached back to the beginning of
Jim Jimmy has loans ownership to not
just show how he hires people and
ultimately how he fires them it was very
important for me to like get inside the
details about how these dismissals had
gone but the other reason was because
remember he was his offices for his
family business that he brilliantly
turned into a billion-dollar we were
raided by the FBI and the IRS and I
think if that had not happened
the Browns wouldn't be this way in there
Jimmy because he wasn't going to be in
Cleveland all the time the family was
always going to stay in Knoxville and
when that raid happened and he
eventually had to sort of let go of that
former life and put his energy and his
identity into the Browns that's where I
think you saw a lot of the problems
coming and so we'll just see what
happens
I don't know how this is gonna all play
out I know South workers some of ESPN
and ESPN comm The Clash of the Cleveland
Browns how Hugh Jackson Jimmy Haslam and
Baker Mayfield collided check it out on
espn.com and ESPN it's a it's a great
read
from your reporting let's get into some
of the here and now from your reporting
whose choice was Baker Mayfield was that
Dorsey Hugh Jackson didn't want him or
he said that Todd Haley poisoned the
team and Baker Mayfield against him I
mean what what happened earlier this
year best you can tell Seth okay so
Baker was a unit was basically a
unanimous choice I mean people were a
little worried about his height but it
was essentially a unanimous choice and I
might be told that during musashi Brown
era some of the research that they were
doing actually had Baker number one so
Baker goes number one and then Hard
Knocks happens and immediate put the
Browns issues on full display in front
of everyone to watch and enjoy and
consume and then you see the team on the
field this year it was a really I team
because in one sense they were going to
overtime almost half of their games
during the first part of the season so
they were playing hard for hue and yet
you saw hue talking about how he had to
take more control of the offense with
Haley Baker wasn't playing well you know
obviously he's a rookie so it's gonna
take some time but it wasn't like this
looked like they had it together and um
so then they lose to the Steelers the
Monday after the game John Dorsey and
owner Jimmy Haslam come into Hugh
Jackson's office and they tell him
they're gonna go in a different
direction she was upset about this he
felt like that he had written the team
out during these tough years when they
were going to lose and everyone knew
they were going to lose and so he was
shocked and he asked why and John Dorsey
said because the team is quitting and
that I'm told very much upset Hugh
because again they had gone to overtime
and we're very close to having a really
good record at that point and he told
them to get the F out of his office yeah
that'll get you fired so so but here's
the thing I'm wondering though okay and
because from what we found out on this
show we had the broadcast or iron eagle
on the show a few weeks ago and he did
that last Steelers Browns game and I
asked him about the situation that he
saw in Cleveland playing out
and he told a story about him and Dan
Fouts going into a pre broadcast meeting
with the head coach Hugh Jackson and
hall-of-famer Dan Fouts asked you how
come you're not running Moore Oklahoma
type plays for Baker Mayfield why aren't
you doing more of that to which iron
said Hugh Jackson said I agree and they
were just kind of looking each other
going what sort of answer is that from a
head coach of a team so from your
reporting what do you think was
happening there with him and Haley and
and Baker and clearly something was
dysfunctional that became more
functional with of all people as you
point on your piece Greg Williams so
what do you think says yeah hasn't
wanted Hugh Jackson to not just be a
sort of one of those head coaches it's
like a glorified play collar he wanted
him to be a leader and be more of a CEO
so they bring in Todd Haley which Hugh
Jackson was on board with and then they
bring in they bring in Todd Haley and
give him autonomy over the Austin and
when the offense wasn't playing well I'm
told that he wanted to assert some
control over the offense and with Haley
did not take well too and so you had
this weird situation where a huge
accident the head coach the team he
feels like he can't assert control over
his own offense you have Todd Haley who
you know basically doing whatever he
wants because he was given that option
to do so and then you know after all of
this you know it's clearly not working
and it's starting to spill out into the
public and they're arguing in Hugh
Jackson's offense office and then both
of them end up getting fired in the same
day and so I don't think the offense
dramatically changed after Todd Haley
was gone I think that like Freddie
kitchens admitted as much at his press
conference that you know it's the same
plays they were doing the same things I
think that like a team needed that team
definitely just needed a new dose of
energy and leadership and I think that
Greg Williams to his credit and Freddie
kitchens were able to provide it so then
what what based on your
your discussions of everyone either on
the record or whatever you could share
as background with us here set from what
you gleaned from all the people the
animus between Baker Mayfield and and
Hugh Jackson would be would be what okay
I mean oh where did that all come from
laid out well I think that i think Baker
was accurate when he said you know I
think he called him a fake on Instagram
and I think that's what he saw I'm not
saying it's totally legitimate but I
think that like there was a sense of the
building and again this goes back to the
power structure that and the reporting
structure is that the owner sets up that
you realized that he felt like that the
Browns and their direction especially
under Sashi Brown were way worse than
what he thought there's a lot of
disputing about that but that's how I
think that's how he felt and so I think
that when you have the odor being the
tiebreaker you have a lot of fighting
and a lot of your self survival starts
to kick in and so I think that like you
realized that he was in a very difficult
situation and you know I think that he
fought to keep his job as best he could
and in the process probably alienating
some people in the building
Seth workers from here on the Rich Eisen
show I'll tell you just having this
conversation with you and hearing what I
hear and knowing what I know and and and
obviously what I just read in your piece
I think the kitchens hire is gonna work
out because one thing that he is not
Freddie kitchens from what I have been
told about everybody knows him and what
he definitely comes across as as a
person
one thing that he is not is a political
animal like every other person in your
piece you know like he's just a football
coach who played you know who played
football in Alabama and who just wants
to coach football and talk football and
that's it and I think Baker responds to
that and if Dorsey provides the right
groceries and it allowed to do it maybe
the Browns finally have it right here
well so I think there's two things
number one is obviously you know did
Jimmy Haslam hire the right guy in John
Dorsey in party kitchens and will they
end up being good together
and we'll kitchen to be a good coach you
know so there's the on-field product and
the continuity and staying ahead of the
curve and staying ahead of Defense's and
allowing Baker to flourish and then
there's the other thing
which is when you have a team that so
star for a franchise quarterback finally
gets one and that guy almost ends up
having more power than maybe he should
and you know you saw I saw that in
Washington where you know
rg3 became a favorite of Dan Snyder and
that serves as a mechanism to undermine
the coaches and so I think those are the
two things that are really interesting
to me
looking forward but you know I was at
the party kitchens press conference and
I mean you know they sort of framed it
is not a win the press conference hire
yet I thought he came across incredibly
genuine credibly smart incredibly
ambitious
and we'll see you know he did a
phenomenal job the last half of the year
till he did and we'll see if they're
able to stay ahead of the curve and then
last one for you what do you make of his
first his first moves head coaches tell
Gregg Williams you're out I mean I guess
is one of those things that it just
couldn't it couldn't work where where
suddenly he's now the boss of the guy
who was the interim boss is that it just
just seemed to unworkable or what do you
make of that Seth I don't know you know
I just think that like I don't have any
any specific insights to that other than
I think that once Greg Williams knew
that he wouldn't be retained as a head
coach I think he probably knew this you
know he's looking to go somewhere else
great job Seth just fun stuff and I
really appreciate it no any any time I
wanted you on after the Belichick Brady
one man I mean but that that one that
what that one was real hot Seth almost
particularly you know we can talk about
that what if you want to my last one for
you on that are you surprised with all
that you gleaned from that piece in that
article that here they are back in Super
Bowl 53 together saying they love each
other I'm not surprised that they're
back together like again that stuff was
always coming from inside the building
but if you you know I was always a
little skeptical that that the three of
them wouldn't be back but I do think
that like I'm surprised based on how
they performed especially you know
against the Titans you had that loss
against the dolphin
that cause some home-field advantage and
you know they are professionals and they
are perfectionist and even if I think
they're they've been getting along very
well this year Jeff Darlington and ESPN
had a great report about you know how
politics treating Brady like a 41 year
old man
more so than he has in years past and
that things couldn't have continued as
they were but they've both changed and I
think that you know they are tough to
beat for 60 minutes it's an I mean it's
we see it all the time but it's like
once D Ford was called for that penalty
either this is over because you could
never ever I'm Brady a second chance I
thought the same thing Seth I mean they
really are in terms of scheme and an
execution the greatest one-two punch
together it's it's it's unbelievable
thanks again for the call Seth
appreciate it we'll chat down the line I
bet you bet seth wickersham at seth
wickersham on twitter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience